nous avons rencontré Jannie à temps
rouge chez elle son centre de
ressourcement ouvert avec l'aide de son
mari et de ses quatre enfants na ni un
hôtel ni une chambre d'ôte un peu des
deux à la foi mais c'est surtout un
concept unique d'accueil de huit
chambres personnalisées dans un décor
raffiné et des conditions optimal pour
un séjour de récupération de calme de
détente de sérénité et de joie du
partage de son coup de foudre pour la
Réunion voilà sais an à la construction
pas à pas de ce petit coin charmant et
original
cette retraitée de l'éducation nationale
nous emmène faire le tour de la
christophine sa propriété touristique
pas tout à fait comme les autres nous
avions de multiples talents dans la
famille ou et lorsque donc je suis
arrivée ici c'était très beau j'ai pensé
que ça pouvait être justement 800 m
d'altitude les gens respirent ça se
passe bien d'autres part bon ben il il y
avait ce verger
euh la nature vraiment et je me suis dit
bon ben allons faire quelque chose et
allons offrir cette prestation là aux
personne parce que bon je pense qu'ici
il y avait vraiment rien de de de cette
de cet ordre là ouis bon il y a si la
osse évidemment mais si la osse c'est
autre chose et puis ici a il y a rien de
médical ici c'est juste de la de la
détente on est on est bien on est on est
tranquille et puis voilà quoi c'est sans
prétenion je
il y a pas de de désir
de ENF les gens se retapent quoi bien
sûr parce qu'il y a des touristes de qui
qui de l'extérieur qui viennent aussi
quelque fois parfois mais justement par
également curieusement c'est bouche à
oreille aussi c'est-à-dire que c'est des
personnes qui sont parties en métropole
par exemple et qui ont parlé à des amis
et alors à ce moment-là ils viennent à
la Réunion et il passe un petit un petit
séjour à la christophine on a eu des
anglais on a eu des Suisses quand même
bon évidemment on ne refuse pas les
personnes qui ont envie de de rester là
je veux pas les touristes on les accepte
et avec grande joie avec grand plaisir
mais disons que c'est vrai que je
préfère et que nous
préférons accueillir des personnes qui
sont vraiment de lit de la Réunion quoi
d'accord voilà c'est pas par hasard que
s'appelle la christophine ah non c'est
pas par hasard parce que la christophine
ça veut dire enfin ça veut dire c'est le
chouchou hein c'est le alors bon il y
avait beaucoup de Chouchou sur le
terrain quand on est arrivé la première
fois et donc on a pensé au chouchou mais
chouchou c'est pas très joli donc on a
préféré christophine qui sonne mieux
puis bon Saint-Christophe c'est le
patron des voyageurs oui donc pour
accueillir ici les les personnes ben ça
nous semblait vraiment quelque chose
donc christophine bon il y a aussi mon
fils qui aime beaucoup les
Christau donc crristau fine ça faisait
penser un petit peu aussi à à chisto ce
qui fait que ben on a gardé christophine
on a trouvé que ça sonnait bien voilà
comme vous allez pouvoir le voir c'est
un petit établissement hein ce n'est pas
véritablement bon bien que ça ça ait les
comment
dirais-je les prestations nécessaires
pour mériter le les deux étoiles ou ce
n'est quand même pas l'hôtel classique
quoi ça n'a rien à voir avec avec ce que
on attend de de l'hôtellerie
quoi
est-ce que le client lui dans les
prestations il a droit à une
alimentation particulière disons que on
on cuisine plutôt enfin un peu un peu
diététique c'està-dire on essaie de
faire léger de ne pas avoir de de sauce
grasse des choses lourdes léger mais
disons
que Dominique qui qui s'occupe de la
cuisine il invente tout le temps c'est
jamais deux fois la même chose et bon on
a vraiment un repas assez complet assez
équilibré mais non on n'est pas ni bio
ni ni macrobo non non nous sommes nous
mangeons un peu de tout et ce qu'il y a
aussi c'est que bon si on a des
personnes qui sont vraiment
végétariennes à ce moment-là on s'adapte
il suffit de nous téléphoner euh
quelques jours avant bon dire ben moi
par exemple je n'aime pas la viande je
je préfère le poisson donc à ce
moment-là Dominique va inventer c mais
alors 1 heure avant il sait pas ce qu'il
va faire à manger ce qui m'oblige moi à
avoir une grande réserve de dans les
frigos parce que sinon dans les haut ici
c'est vrai qu'on ne trouve pas
forcément tout ce dont on a besoin quoi
mais on prévoit et puis on arrive
j'espère j'espère he jusqu'à maintenant
personne ne s'est plain et on a on
arrive à satisfaire les clients et puis
bon on n' pas voulu faire des repas du
style créole non plus parce que bon ben
c'est pas la vocation non plus de c'est
très bien fait dans les dans les
chambres les tables d'ôes et les gites
ici donc on allallait pas faire en
double emploi quoi est-ce que le centre
a une particularité une particularité
ben je crois la convivialité euh la on
essaie de d'être d'être vraiment en
harmonie avec les personnes qui sont là
et c'est c'est ça la particularité du
centre bien sûr mais on peut dire aussi
que vous partagez votre propre vie de
famille avec clients absolument parce
que nous sommes nous habitons dans la
nous avons notre chambre la chambre des
filles et nous sommes là euh nous vivons
dans la dans dans dans le centre quoi
nous sommes au centre du centre très
bien là comme ça c'est n c'est notre
chambre quoi le décor pour vous a une
très grande place euh dans le centre ah
oui je j'ai j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur
les couleurs bon là on a le blanc et
l'or j'adore la lumière et l'or c'est la
lumière le blanc également donc là j'ai
vraiment travaillé et ça ce sont mes
couleurs c'est c'est ce que j'aime donc
pour cette chambre là je me suis réservé
le blanc et or dans l'entrée on a pu
voir aussi que c'était blanc et or parce
que c'est c'est c'est ce qui permet
aussi de se détendre d'avoir cette
lumière et d'être très très tout de
suite quand on rentre on ressent il y a
tout de suite cette décontraction qui
qui
saisit est-ce que vous pensez avoir des
remèdes aux agressions extérieures
oui alors remède est un bien grand mot
parce que ici il n'est pas question de
guérison voilà il est uniquement
question de prévention justement
c'est-à-dire que de faire que les gens
se sentent bien et donc se sentant bien
ben c'est vrai que il y a malgré tout
bien que nous soyons une île tropicale
ici pas mal de facteurs de stress de de
de de tension
et oui c'est certain que bon lorsque les
personnes viennent faire une séance de
relaxation sophrologique enfin de types
sophrologiqu je dis bien parce que ce
n'est pas uniquement de la relaxation
sophrologique c'est la relaxation
profonde en alpha oui et on a aussi le
jacuzzi alors ça le jacuzzi c'est super
parce que ça ça masse en
profondeur ici ben c'est une chambre
comme vous pouvez le voir
à de lits oui voilà tout à l'heure on a
vu une à grand lit et voilà le le genre
de de de petite chambre que nous
proposons donc pour les personnes qui
viennent à deux mais à Mii ou des choses
comme ça ici ben c'est on a fait un
petit dortoir parce que quelque foois il
y a des amis qui viennent en petite
randonné ou des ch B Mao quand ils
redescendent et ben ils dorment là ils
se reposent ils en profitent pour
prendre un petit jacuzzi
on prend ce qu'on veut c'est à la carte
on fait ce qu'on veut et là on a fait
une petite salle de bain voilà et bon on
essaie de ou quand il y a des petites
familles des des des en général bon les
enfants j'adore les enfants parce que
j'ai toujours travaillé toute ma vie
avec des enfants donc pour moi les
enfants c'est sacré mais c'est vrai que
venir ici avec les enfants c'est pas
très conseillé non plus est-ce que c'est
à la portée de n'importe quel budget de
venir faire un séjour chez vous ah alors
euh sur les prix nous avons été aussi
euh enfin notre c'est dans notre
philosophie hein nous ne cherchons pas
donc particulièrement à faire rentrer
des finances et par conséquent nous
cherchons à faire plaisir aux personnes
d'accord nous faisons surtout justement
des des comment dirais-je des packaging
enfin
B donc et nous avons une presse aation
globale si possible ce qui fait que les
prix si on regarde chaque prix c'est pas
très cher pour pouvoir permettre aux
gens de d'avoir un maximum de prestation
de choix voilà on pour citer juste un
exemple par exemple le fauteuil que nous
avons vu tout à l'heure benah c'est 50
francs pour tr/4 d'heure quoi donc c'est
pas excessif mais seulement bon
évidemment quand on cumule quand on
prend un fauteuil un
jacuzzi une une relaxation etci bon ben
c'est vrai que que ça finit par par
faire une certaine somme mais bon
justement c'est pour permettre aux
personnes de un maximum de personnes de
pouvoir bénéficier de des prestations
ici en
racinement ensuite on prend on monte
doucement le serceau devant on inspire
pousse bien devant au homme nai plus
peur n'ai plus peur et éclaire le
profond de ton cœur observe le sacré
secret de ta mémoire secrète ouvre l'œil
et traverse le plan du miroir n'ai plus
peur éclaire le profond de ton corps car
l'envers de la vie n'est nullement la
mort éclaire éclaire tout jusqu'au fond
de ton âme et sur tes ombres troubles
élève cette flamme qui danse avec ta
peur n'ai plus peur de ta peur toute
nuit a toujours l'étoile pour lueur le
noir à sa lumière qui dévoile l'erreur
laisse monter tes pleurs et cri et crie
et pleur entre au dedans de toi et
refais le chemin soit l'enfant qui
renais du noir vers la lumière cesse de
tout prévoir laisse venir demain sois
vivant et respire inspire ton présent
expire ton passé expire ton hier laisse
s'ouvrir les vannes et s'engouffrer les
EAU au fil de tes canaux laisse le flux
vivant librement s'écouler et rouler
chaque flot respire à plein poumon que
tes cellules vibrent lève le voile
obscur et désormais sois
libre